[Music]  you know what they call trees in a  forest fire fuel you know what they call  the trees left up on the fire goes by  they called them the standing dead  [Music]  monster is dead okay  of course yes his pride got hurt that  happens sometimes  you don't have to worry about anything  Joe there comes a time when man needs  some more to hang his hat on got this  homicide my head I need to do something  about it you understand I think your  father has a woman out here oh you  wouldn't do that  no why do you think that do things they  either go crazy or it's a woman  [Music]  what are the best true people are drawn  to things they shouldn't be  I was dressed like this all the time  when I was younger it's probably nice to  know your parents will once not your  parents  does your mother do something that he  would like to have to tell me about  I feel like I wake up  [Music]  what's going to happen to us  [Music]  [Music]